thank God he will not sing again until  the child as well I'm certain of it  David Foster opens up to et Canada about  Michael bublé's son Michael revealed  three-year-old Noah was diagnosed with  cancer earlier this month  your name's Justin almond you're the  fear in everything I think Michael right  now is in a huge bubble as you would  expect them when this happens everything  shuts down around you I'm sure he feels  the love from the millions of people  ezvid shape he's got good doctors around  him and we will hope and pray for a  great outcome which I believe that they  will have David became a mentor to  Michael after working on music together  over the years Mike's a guy that is such  a good man with a beautiful family and  he's got a lot of good climber coming  his way because he's done a lot of good  for a lot of people